the tanks are
naturally not real, so their
armament also
looks like the original, but it is
covered by weapons that shoot
detailed layers my name is sergey
akimov
I am an architect builder and with friends we are
creating new models of
tanks
on a bukin scale
[music]
you are deported at night
and mother habré
[  music]
arafa keys and
we have three people I-thought
friend yuri my friend sergey we chose this activity
spontaneously wanted to celebrate the
anniversary of May 9 for us this is a very
serious date we wanted to
drive a tank in our village with some kind of
reserve parade I voiced the idea
to create a tank then I immediately realized and
realized that this is too difficult a task but
overcoming difficulties makes it
working on this a huge number of
trials and a huge number of
mistakes  we have cars based on the
shell company in 1 now we have
two cars planned to kill this  zu tanks and calls for
panzer huntsman 1 and self-propelled artillery
spartanivka is insanely Donetsk and there are a
huge number of skeptics who
periodically appear at various
festivals with stupid questions why we
do what we want to show, that is, in
any case, when you talk about what
tanks do, it
goes unnoticed
[  music] of
course it’s very interesting then our
names can turn out to be our children how
these cars looked many, many
years ago how they move how
they work
suspension rumbles caterpillars a time machine
through hands through any technique we
attract guys to patriotic
tune